Україна зможе стати енергонезалежною
і відмовитися від імпортного газу в найближчі 5 років
завдяки відкриттю доступу до українських надр.
У цьому переконаний прем’єр-міністр України Володимир Гройсман.
- Ми починаємо розкручувати дуже складну закриту систему, -
ми в принципі її зруйнували - доступу до українських надр.
Я вважаю, що в найближчі 5 років
цей відкритий доступ дасть можливість нам
не купляти газ за валюту, а виробляти його в Україні.
Про здобуття енергетичної незалежності країни
вже найближчими роками українська влада заявляла не раз.
Приміром, наприкінці 2017 року Володимир Гройсман
уже запевняв: до 2020 року Україна буде в змозі
не лише обійтися без імпортованого "блакитного палива",
але й продавати своє іншим країнам.
Повна відмова від імпорту газу в Україні
цілком імовірна, але для цього потрібно скоротити
споживання газу, а також збільшити обсяги
власного видобутку, наголошують оглядачі.
За "Стратегією сталого розвитку-2020", схваленою
українським урядом кілька років тому, до 2020 року
видобуток власного газу мав зрости до трохи більше 27 млрд кубометрів.
Із них 20 мільярдів повинна була видобувати
державна компанія "Укргазвидобуток", а решту -
приватний сектор. Утім, як показує досвід
останніх років, певний приріст є, однак він незначний.
Приміром, у 2016-му видобуток компаній
із державним капіталом становив 15,9 мільярдів кубометрів,
у 2017-му - 16,4, а у 2018-му - 16,6. Загалом в Україні
торік видобули 21 мільярд кубометрів газу, а спожили - 32.
І це при тому, що Україна - в топ-четвірці Європи
за газовими покладами разом із Росією, Норвегією та Нідерландами.
Це  підтверджують рейтинги ОРЕС, British Petroleum
та міненергетики США. В підземних надрах України -
від 600 мільярдів до понад трильйона кубометрів
доведених покладів газу. І щонайменше уп’ятеро більше,
згідно з непідтвердженими розрахунками.
Щоправда, деякі експерти вказують на те, що
багатства українських надр дещо перебільшені.
Мовляв, переважна більшість існуючих родовищ "Укргазвидобування"
значною мірою вже вичерпані. Відповідно
збільшити видобуток за їхній рахунок навряд чи вийде.
Потрібні нові розробки, а для цього - чималі кошти.
Наростити власний видобуток газу в найближчі 3-5 років дійсно реально,
якщо інвестувати в це понад три мільярди доларів,
вважають газові експерти. Утім, сумніваються у
економічній доцільності.
Разом із тим досягти запланованих показників
можна лише за умови, якщо вдасться подолати
корупцію і бюрократію в цій галузі, а також вирішити
проблему олігархічного впливу.
Як зазначають у "Нафтогазі", замість очікуваних
80 ліцензій на розробку нових родовищ
"Укргазвидобування" за останні кілька років отримала лише 17.
До того ж, процес блокують обласні ради. Приміром,
в одному з ключових газовидобувних регіонів
України - на Полтавщині - за три роки компанія
"Укргазвидобування" отримала від місцевої облради
63 відмови щодо нових площ для видобутку або розширення існуючих.
Усе це гальмує розвиток галузі та сповільнює
нарощення власного видобутку газу в Україні.